what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to a
kevin samuels clip
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell
and um don't leave a comment and let me
know if you guys agree or
disagree with the things that kevin
samuels says during this clip
all right do this
all right that's one person
two people
okay here's my is ishmael
you ready wave
wave if you're ready to go all right
all right hello what's going on
how are you how old are you i'm 28.
all right what's the disagreement um
i don't feel uh even
if black men reach the certain level
that they're uh
that we should aspire to reach i don't
think uh the black women will follow us
i feel like 80 of them will still [ __ ]
on us
and uh leave us hanging why first of all
you said i feel twice
the manosphere hates the word i feel i
don't know why
i guess you would say from my experience
they still [ __ ] on you even if you start
to achieve that's probably how you would
have said it
see any issue with that
no that's a problem
as a man you shouldn't worry about how
you feel
so thinking what we do it's one of the
things we talk about women all the time
they always say i feel i feel i feel
so what makes black women biologically
different than any other group of women
biologically yes
there is no difference
then why would they not respond to the
same evolutionary biology type things
from what i've seen from anecdotal
experience
uh
it's like it's it's a temporary it's a
temporary con
it's a temporary uh reaction
[Music]
i'm in atlanta atlanta
yes sir so why does the divorce rate
drop dramatically
for black couples as well over an income
of 250 000
huh i didn't know that
maybe because you're not part of that
group damn
damn
see if you're going to say something
like that i'm going to challenge it
because basically what you're putting
out here is you don't feel black women
are going to
okay i'll go with that but why
based upon what it's um it's
what i've seen my entire life black
women have been my
entire life they've been your what
my enemy what do you mean
um um whether it's
me whether it's people that i know or
people that
i'm even related to if there
are strides towards uh success that are
being made
there's an active effort to
get in the way of the progress of what
it is that we're doing like honestly
like
what does that mean though you come in
and say black women have been my enemy
you're gonna have to give me a specific
okay let you go man i'm trying to
i recently uh dated a woman who
uh was pursuing a dual doctorate degree
in medicine and in chemistry
throughout the entire relationship uh
throughout the entire relationship the
only time that
we didn't have um an argument
or we didn't have any kind of ridiculous
back and forth
is when we were having sex you know what
i'm saying but
but you allowed that behavior it's the
same reason when i say that when women
say that men are trash like men are the
worst
men that hate that hate a certain type
of women like black women in this case
it's the black women they're choosing to
date i know a lot of
black women that are super nice super
compassionate um
you know that have definitely qualities
to be a wife but if you're choosing
women
that treat
you like that and you don't cut it off
that's your own fault i hate i hate to
say it
like once the orgasm was out there how
do you 28.
how long do you want to hear i've known
her for eight years dated her for one
and you did it to what end what was it
what was the intended outcome
to what in yeah they didn't have a
purpose i was uh
i was looking um i was looking uh i was
interested in marrying her
you were dated over okay and what do you
do for a living
i'm a musician and an uber driver oh
no oh no
no he why'd you say that dude
i know siri are you trolling me ninja no
i'm not ninja what your date
your enemy is your pocketbook damn
i know don't come here to talk about
black women
man see
i mean are you being serious bro
um i am but the finances is definitely
something
no no no no hell no no a black woman
who's dating doing
you you actually came in here to tell me
that you dated a black woman who's
pursuing two dual doctorates
i'm a phd and you're a guy you're an
uber driver and a musician that's not a
problem
except you frame black women as your
enemy and your enemy is your inability
to be productive on a serious level
damn that's not currently true for me
well here's the thing i talked about
what makes black women different on an
evolutionary
biological scale than any other group of
women you could not say that i asked you
about the decrease in the marital
the divorce rates over a quarter of a
million dollars for a couple you didn't
know about that
yourself in your anecdotal experience
but unless you make
that your anecdotal experience has been
i would guess that he feels like he was
making like
strides towards becoming a high value
man or towards like getting to a certain
income level and
she didn't care which i'm not even gonna
lie
backs up everything kevin says as he
says that women have a hard time with
men that like make less than them
do you respect yours well so
okay so outside of me i have mentors
that uh i work with my ultimate point is
you're 28 years old you're too young to
be trying to talk about getting married
anyway
see you haven't found yourself
and if i go with what you said your
failure
and relationships are justified by
calling black women your enemy
instead of looking in the mirror and
saying where am i
at i do that every day
and why and why what makes you said you
were looking at her to be a
a wife possibly what makes you a husband
outside from what standpoint can you
provide for a family
not yet no then then bro then
then you were dating this woman with the
item merrier and you couldn't even
provide for a family
but it's interesting that women nowadays
expect men to have it all figured out
um i know that's why kevin suggests
age gap dating but like when my mom met
my dad it wasn't like my dad was
rich you know that came later and i
think that's what he's trying to get at
and kevin's like nah if you can't afford
a wife you don't get one
your problem isn't the women man the
problem see this is the problem with too
many of us as black men
we look to we we don't have power
we're not trying to be serious i mean no
disrespect
but i i'm tired of hearing black men who
are musicians and rappers and
and producers and actors and massage
therapists and uber drivers and chefs
where's the trade where's the profession
where's the real world something you
walk into a chamber of commerce meeting
with a business card and say this is who
i am and what i do to where
other men will take you seriously
so then according to kevin samuels can
entertainers not be high value men
um because a lot of entertainers
work hard and ends up like working out
for them they end up making a lot of
money and doing well
so it's interesting to me like matthew
mccon mcconaughey i can't even say
say his name but i would imagine he
would be a high value man like he got a
ton of girls
like but now he's married i think but
you guys get what i'm saying right
was that rhetorical or did you want me
to
no i'm asking you because if you were to
go into a chamber of commerce meeting on
any on any given
tuesday or thursday how many
musician uber drivers do you think you'd
meet that were non-black
no all right none
it's not where i plan on staying or what
i'm working towards in the future
i get it i get that however
you were dating a woman who is heavily
degreed
and women respond to power unfortunately
she dwarfed you in power potential
so the only place you could dominate and
show any power is in the bedroom
because she did not have to take you
seriously you weren't on the same level
damn this is why i can't allow to stand
when you come in here saying black women
or this a black woman or that
are you a competitive black man
yes i would say so uh competitive
against who
damn why do they do this to themselves
you know
you know what you're walking into um
against uh i guess like people in my tax
bracket
i don't want to stay here i'm trying to
get to the top one percent
okay well that's the main thing
becoming a productive competitive
successful man
men who are that way tend to have fewer
problems because they have more leverage
did you have that's something you want
to realize watching your content
well so it's not black women it's not
women
right you have little leverage in a
relationship with a woman who's going to
get tutors and this is what i
what i say like in my opinion that
dating is easier for men than women
because one women you're always under
you know there's a clock that's ticking
all the time
um and that's just not guys it's not a
fun way to live
and second thing um
for men like you can always
improve where you're at if you're a girl
if you don't have like a pretty face
you're kind of born where you're born
but as a guy you could you can change it
like he might not be a high value man
today but he could be in five years
please and i answered what i'm saying
you said i was i asked you how long have
you known her eight years
you've known her long enough to know who
she is and what she's about
you said you were with her for one year
i said to what end you said to marriage
and you're not in a position to be a
husband
you can't provide for a family you
shouldn't have been in a relationship
that's the ultimate answer you shouldn't
have been in a relationship she should
have been on out somewhere else
dealing with somebody who wanted what
she wanted but you
are not in a position to deal with any
women to that end
damn casually socially sure we're
talking about a wife
you can't provide well okay so
that that goes against uh stuff that
you've said previously
because what i make um currently right
now
is average income um i average about
45 000 a year goes against what i've
said
um you're saying that uh that in order
for
for someone to even consider marriage
he's also said that women shouldn't pick
potential
which um that they should that women
well he said that like most women won't
pick potential that's what he said
to be making in the top one percent or
not at least what if i said that when
have i said that
isn't that what you're saying right now
you're saying that because no sir
no no you said it conflicts with what i
said and i asked you what did i say
and you just said well you're saying in
order to be married you need to be in
the top one percent
do you understand really completely all
right okay
no that's not what i'm no stop no no no
no no that's not what i said
that means that the only people who
could get married in the top one percent
i asked you could you provide for a
family i didn't ask you how much money
you made i asked you and you said no
at 45 000 i mean it's not then that's
all you need to know you shouldn't be
looking to marry anybody if you can't
provide
i told her that i needed time to build
it up it doesn't matter what you told
her you shouldn't have been with her
okay she was going for two direct do
all right man see we have a problem
if you pick a woman who's going to
school and getting dual doctorates
and you're an uber driver and a musician
you're unequally yoked man you know that
and if you wanted her to wait on your
potential
i think you're too young to be worried
about any of this stuff anyway and what
i'm hearing is a lack of maturity
because you haven't got there
yet
he wants the benefits but not he doesn't
he doesn't
want to he wants the benefits of being
rich without actually being rich
if her if she had a father who was a
productive competitive successful man do
you think he would have accepted you as
an adequate son-in-law
no then what it's not about her
i was saying black women in general that
was just the relationship
no no but but we always are talking to
themselves you talk about black women in
general and just like with black women i
get specific
you can't talk about general if you
can't handle it specifically in your
life
you can't come in and say that about
black women being your enemy how is that
woman your enemy
i feel like despite the things that i
was how was that woman your enemy
every uh i mean throughout the entire
relationship man
you shouldn't have been in the french
coast relationship
i agree with you on that point
take ownership and accountability for
the fact that you shouldn't have been
trying to
no you don't i do oh my god
kevin was like i'm done i'm done with
this man
okay i'm gonna listen to one more person
from this interview
okay
okay boom you make them more comfortable
to say the things that they say
that's my only disagreement okay
oh damn i didn't give anybody a platform
i can't control what people say you
gotta listen to hear what people have to
say what do y'all think i am
what do you think this is you don't know
what somebody's gonna say until they say
it
hello
good evening mrs samuels can you hear me
man how old are you
i am 22 years old what's the
disagreement
my disagreement uh is more of a
counterpoint towards your image shifting
i believe it was uh
it was ruggish um refined was the third
one
forgive me it was rugged refined and
the three keystones uh three
foundational images
they exist what's the disagreement uh in
terms of image shifting how can we
um how can how can black men that are
more
towards the refined or the less majority
how can they
be in these positions for a relationship
i know i'm thinking a little bit too
early
but in terms of people that are either
if
you're fit man you fit into one of these
categories
more or less one way what's the
disagreement that the categories exist
uh no no the disagreement is mostly how
can
people uh black men that are more into
the minority
um categories be seen more since like
young man that's not a disagreement it's
a question
disagreement is a disagreement is
you said okay this one's this tastes
good and i think it doesn't
this is not a different thing it looks
like he talks about
this guy for a while i got too many
people on here
let's try this
hello hey how you doing
good how old are you 35.
all right what's your disagreement um
this first of all i want to commend you
on your show i mean i watch you every
day so you're doing a phenomenal job i
think you
you really try to highlight and i think
a lot of the the
listeners that i've been listening to
they don't watch your show
so they're not familiar with your
content but my disagreement
would be that i do feel that there
should be
a better way to bring the men and women
together because from what i'm hearing
there's a lot of harshness coming um
in tone and i don't think a lot of women
are used to that because of the society
we're in
so your disagreement is with my tone
[Music]
i respect that i respect that
i can respect that um i just feel that
women are accustomed to i just feel he
hates that word to me
were you raised by your calendar yes
i'm asking because you keep talking
about feeling how you feel
i feel i feel that is a big trigger word
especially around men's content
women talk about how they feel
tell me about what you know and what you
think
damn gotcha well what i know is
women have a very hard time with men
that are
as strong toned as you come across
um they don't seem to receive that as as
well as someone with a softer tone
really does it matter how they receive
it doesn't matter what they do about it
you know yeah no i gotta that's a
question i'm asking you
what matters more it matters more what
they do what they do there
and then i challenge you to go look at
what some of my
uh detractors people who tell women what
they want to hear
and go find the amount of women who tell
them you saved my marriage i'm getting
married because of you you made me a
better woman i didn't like what you had
to say but now i'm better
go look in their comment section go look
at how many videos the women have made
to them
and come back and tell me i will say the
one thing that is refreshing about kevin
samuels is
um you can tell that he truly believes
what he says
and that he's not pandering or just
trying to sell things
that that's one thing i like about kevin
samuels and i do think it's a fresh a
breath of fresh air to have like a
dating coach that actually tells you
something that's true
um i don't agree with a hundred percent
of the stuff he says as you guys know
but you know it is refreshing to
to say like it is your job to stay in
shape for a guy like
that is your job whether you like it or
not but
where other dating coaches i mean this
is just the first example that comes
to my head but where other dating
coaches might say
oh he shouldn't leave you or like he
should love you no matter what
you know etc they rank rank ranked next
to mine
you're right uh my question is as a
black man why are you coming here making
an emotional argument
about tone when you when we got such a
problem with our women
well i think i'm making that argument
simply because more black women
they're listening to your content i see
more and more people having discussions
well let me let me reframe this
why as a man are you giving me the
emotional argument based upon outcomes
i don't really see that many out that
that much of a good outcome but honestly
um who forgive for them
well black women i mean i no no black
women my tone
my tone aside i'm getting outcomes
the people who tell them you're a queen
and a goddess i know but how
how do you know what percentage of
dating coaches get
out how would you measure that like
serious question
because i'm sure there's people that
have said that derrick jacks
or whatever that guy's name was got them
outcomes right
maybe i'll look it up are they getting
women married
going back to their husbands reframing
how they look at men
you say you follow my content right
you're right you're right
who's getting the outcome you're you're
getting more outcome i mean i will
so as a man how are you going to come to
me as a man who's getting a better
outcome and tell me about
tone well simply because i just feel
like
again what you're feeling
what i was trying to say is that some
people don't receive
your message because of the way you say
things and kevin is saying i don't care
you do it that's this summarized
see the problem is when you say this you
weaken us
you sound soft saying this [ __ ] who's
the head look at his
see his brow like furrow because you
sound like
listen to what the men are gonna go back
and go look in the comment section after
this video
and i feel i feel i feel okay i do have
one
serious critique of the manosphere um
they only take viewpoints that agree
with them so if they have a girl
that comes forward like me right if i if
i say something that agrees with the man
of sphere they'll say wow
finally a rational thinking woman
someone that's logical
but if i say something you know what i
don't agree with that they'll say i'm
emotional
okay let's say i'm a man right they do
the same thing if a guy
says something that disagrees with them
they'll say
that it's like beta male or if they say
something that agrees with them they'll
say he's an alpha
it's like instead of just taking the
argument which he he is doing now
but i just hate it when they take a look
at the comments
obviously your comments are it's your
following they're gonna
agree with you duh i don't if if i'm
getting a different
outcome which is a better outcome
damn the tone it's the outcome and if
you're saying you see the same outcome
why do you care so much about the tone
because i don't think the majority of
women are receiving what you're saying
the right it's not for the majority of
women and the majority of women are
being told they're queens and goddesses
and what is that doing for the majority
of women
but if the majority of women are not
receiving your content properly if the
majority of women are being told they're
queens and goddesses
in your tens what are the outcomes to
that
see this is our problem as black men
right here
want me to moderate my tone when it's
getting a better
outcome than the moderated tones but but
my point is i don't think it's being
received by women
as well as it would be if it was a tad
bit better i'm not trust me
i'm not saying to change your complete
tone that's not what i'm saying because
i respect you
i mean this is the dumbest conversation
i've heard but
what you're making is a feelings based
argument
if you change your tone then what okay
let's say it your way
if i change my tone what percentage
increase do you think i would get
i think you would get a lot more what
percentage increase do you think i would
get
oh damn at least 15 to 20 at least a 15
or 20
increase i don't think so and you're
basing that based on what
just based off i don't think so i don't
think most women
want to hear it genuinely i don't think
most women
want the truth once again like you
mentioned my anecdotal
rights right people just right right you
have nothing to base
kevin what do you expect these are
people just calling into your show
think i want you to sit there and ponder
that you want me to change
what's getting outcomes verifiable
and you're saying 15 to 20 percent based
upon
nothing
that's how men operate that's how we
think and
and i'm challenging you i'm challenging
this because they're going to be black
women they're going to come on and say
yeah i hear what you're saying
but we can't be like this because no
other group of men thinks like this
it is weak thinking no no
it works and if i'm not getting
everybody so what i'm doing
far better than the people telling their
queens the goddesses and you can't come
tell me that if you moderated your
message
you get about 15 to 20 more you can't
say that
i could somebody could easily come along
and say he could lose 50 percent
but you have to understand a lot of
people may only watch your content
not because they're trying to be but do
you understand that they could make the
same
argument you could lose 50 percent
based upon the anecdotal evidence could
they make because i'm not even going to
lie
i think half of his audience is there
because
he's kind of an [ __ ] like people like
to see
a savage someone do make the same
argument you could lose
true or false i mean that's true you
could always lose followers or lose
well so it's a counter argument
and what i'm saying is what you're
saying doesn't make any it's not rooted
in anything other than your feelings
the reason i say that okay first of all
you just said i use the word feelings
too much so i was raised in a household
with both my father and a mother
so my mother is a very strong-willed
person my father is an all he's also a
very strong-willed person
so but he always taught me you catch
more flies with
honey than vinegar or something along
that line but anyway
it's an old school term but he always
used that term so he
he always trained me to say there's a
time and place
to be very strong and stern and there's
a time and place to kind of fall back
and use your softer side
you're watching a platform with the man
who's been on for a year
yeah well i think from from seven going
from 50 000 subscribers to almost a
million
yes who's a professional salesperson who
is trained in what you're talking about
monday through friday i do this yes i
agree
and you're and actually you've been
there you don't think that you don't
think that i know the things you're
talking about
but i also know as a salesperson and as
a marketer as a presenter
you need to people respond to
authenticity
and actual outcomes but i understand it
i'm a marketing manager i understand if
you aren't
then what you're saying is not even make
good business sense
you got it it's based in
what i'm saying is not about business
what i'm saying is
it's about relationships it's about it
it's the dumbest argument i've ever
heard
it's about business you said getting
more people is about increasing an
outcome
it's business it can be both okay but i
thought honestly i thought your content
was about building the black community
building
it is and who's getting a better outcome
who's getting the better damn outcome is
it derek jackson and steve harvey
telling your queens and everything else
is it or is it this have you seen any
videos saying i got
my husband because of derrick jackson
dave jackson saved my marriage steve
harvey did this
have you seen any of those videos of
course i watch all that content no no
you've seen women come out and say i
found my husband
listening to these guys following this
information no but they do
steve harvey has definitely had women
that say they found their husband
because of steve harvey
i've definitely heard that all that
stuff i didn't ask you
okay have you seen any videos saying
that kevin samuels is the reason i'm
married
there are five on my channel right now
yes but they may not just produce that i
mean
i understand that you don't you produce
it you produce results
i will grant you that they may not
produce that or put that content or
information out there to the general
public that's all i'm saying
my thing is you would get more
viewers you would get a better outcome
just i like that
okay you're right i like the outcome i'm
getting i'm just what i'm gonna do
and it's working and until you can show
me something that's gonna work better
show me somebody who has faster growth
more views more consistent outcomes show
me somebody show me one person
give me the business reason to do it
you're right i uh then stop
kevin added there because i don't this
is boring me
um i don't really have i mean i agree
with him i i've definitely
seen steve harvey's stuff though the
people saying they found their husband
because of steve harvey
but let me know in the comments if you
guys agree with kevin or disagree don't
forget to subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell i'll talk to you
guys
next time